well this is straight out of the russian  playbook to try to  through sabotage operations through  false flag operations through  blaming the other guy  to create that pretext to give an excuse  to go in or to make it look like the  ukrainians were the aggressors when in  fact the first aggression was perhaps  even done by russians against russians  to blame the ukrainians so it's all very  dangerous in the way they operate is  america prepared to go to war with  russia  if it invades ukraine  what we are talking about here is  helping the ukrainians to defend  themselves and preparing massive  consequences economic and political for  moscow if it  walks away from the diplomatic table and  chooses aggression instead